absuelto por segunda vez el senado
estadounidense no pudo condenar a donald
trump por incitar a la violencia contra
el capitolio el pasado 6 de enero el ex
presidente celebró su decisión y condenó
el proceso al que fue sometido es un
triste comentario sobre nuestros tiempos
que un partido político en eeuu tenga un
pase libre para denigrar el estado de
derecho y famara las fuerzas del orden
animar a las multitudes disculpar a los
alborotadores y transformar la justicia
en una herramienta de venganza política
sólo 7 republicanos votaron en contra de
trump y aunque es la cifra más alta de
legisladores que han votado para
condenar a un presidente de su propio
partido en un juicio político el número
fue insuficiente ya que necesitaban el
apoyo de 17 de ellos y así completar los
67 votos con los que lo declararía
culpable un resultado que se había
previsto en la escena 7 lo que vimos en
este senado hoy fue un cobarde grupo de
republicanos que aparentemente no tienen
opciones porque tenían miedo de defender
su trabajo respetar la institución en la
que sirven
a pesar de haber votado para absolverlo
el líder de la minoría republicana en el
senado no restó culpas al ex presidente
no hay ninguna duda de que el presidente
trump es práctica y moralmente
responsable de provocar los
acontecimientos de ese día
tavera
no hay duda al respecto las personas que
irrumpieron en este edificio creyeron
que estaban actuando según los deseos e
instrucciones de su presidente
trump es el primer expresidente en
enfrentar un impeachment después de
finalizar su mandato el objetivo del
juicio político era evitar que volviera
a postularse pero mcconnell dijo que
trump no se ha salido con la suya
sugiriendo que podría enfrentar un
proceso penal